he's Cooper cup here on the Rich Eisen
show how are you Cooper I'm good thanks
for coming on the show what was it like
being out there in the the Coliseum
taking on the National Football League
for the first time I have an incredible
experience and even though mm-hmm so I
couldn't help but notice you wear number
18 and that name that number always
resonates for me in the NFL cuz it's
that of the sheriff Peyton Manning is
that on purpose
you were an 18-page you know that's a
good that's not a bad number he wasn't
even on be around organization that
carries a lot of weight but no it wasn't
anything on purpose I like to say it was
but there's just one of the numbers that
was left and I just rolled with it but
that does have some meaning for you
right I mean I know you and Peyton
Manning have some sort of connection
correct yeah be around him and just soak
up as much knowledge as I can for them
and you know and he seems to be a text
message every once in awhile
sandy Congrats so it's pretty pretty
awesome being able to have had the
experience I had around him and so I
assume he's noticed what your number is
done right I mean yeah I would think so
oh he hasn't he's too nice now easy too
cool for school you think on that front
cool I mean it doesn't sound like guys
think he's been a little busy job you
commercials you've been in doing
something doing some big things okay now
let's talk about your journey here
you're from Yakima correct
Washington area from an Eastern
Washington how did you wind up there
were you balled out Cooper you know I
came from school I think really just had
set themselves up well in the football
front we had gone for two straight years
without a winning season at my high
school for I had gotten there and so I
think that didn't help things he dumped
the recruiting and then just coming from
kind of the town there wasn't no much
for football and under the radar but I
was very happy with my time in Eastern
Washington and have all great
friendships and relationships that were
formed there you know
I'm doing my time yeah and you won the
Jerry Rice award for the most
outstanding freshman in any FCS team did
you meet Jerry through that oh no so we
were in the we were in the playoff that
had that ceremony so my parents got to
go over to it but yeah I didn't get the
opportunity to meet them
I did get alchemy and actually this last
summer but Nike but uh I was pretty
bummed yeah yeah he facetimes me
actually found it was the craziest
experiences of my life
walk me through that being facetiming oh
I was just sitting on my desk doing
homework and you know soon they're
preparing for the preparing for that
week ahead we're going to a semifinal
game against Towson and saying they're
doing homework and I got FaceTime for my
mom and I open it up expect me to my mom
and it was Jerry Rice so instead of your
mom you see the face of Jerry Rice what
do you say when that happens all of a
sudden Cooper Cup was the Jerry Rice
Award winner and the Walter Payton Award
winner for most outstanding offensive
player in 2015 two-time Big Sky
Conference Offensive Player of the Year
here on the Rich Eisen show I'll be
honest with you I first heard your name
during the combine when I was preparing
for the combine okay and then at the
draft hearing your name over and over
against Steve Smith pointed you out
he said Corey Davis looks more like most
like Terrell Owens but the best receiver
I think that's available out there is
Cooper Cup what do you think of when you
hear that stuff I have a lot of respect
for the way he plays the game got
actually talked to him a little bit down
the field at the combine obviously
incredible to hear that and they'll have
a little bit of time to talk with him
but you know at the end of the day you
know what anyone says well that's bitter
bad it's really about how you kill
yourself and with you how are you able
to help the team win and that's always
going to be ultimate goal whether you're
you know whatever it takes if it means
you know one catch or ten catches it
doesn't matter I just want to be a part
of helping the Rams win games you know
pursue a Super Bowl
so do you model yourself after Steve
Smith in the in the the talking aspect
of it and if somebody talks to you that
only fires you up is that like you to
now no I just go by the wayside young
ones that I keep my head down do my job
and I don't anything else really kind of
affect me and my goals cooper cup of the
LA Rams after a four catch 76 yard one
touchdown game in his rookie campaign
here and National Football League on the
Rich Eisen show couldn't help but notice
you acted like you've been there before
after scoring the touchdown what'd you
do with the football Cooper
what do you do with the football after
you scored so I talked to the rest my
normal thing and then there wasn't I got
to the sideline so yes if I hug the ball
still that I realized I probably should
kept that one but just you know a force
of habit you know throw the ball to the
rest of the teammates and get to the
sideline so you do not know where that
football is right now no idea if you
could take a mulligan on it would you do
something other than normal thing of
flipping it back to the ref you know no
I probably just yet if I could do it I
probably just hold on to it you know
mm-hm just have a fur keepsake but uh
you know I'm not gonna I don't know if
I'll ever see someone that does a
celebration anything like that you know
I'm always young via flips the rap guy I
think the same thing you know sounds of
the grace is done is just you know act
like you've been there before you know
and I'm on my game after some of the
best that I've ever done and you know
hopefully Billy get there someday but
just you know play my game
so you're 24 correct in the National
Football League and you've got blonde
hair right okay could you pass yourself
off for your coach who's 31 years old
I think if I really tried I really tried
I give it a shot
I think I am a little bit taller no but
you could do that like going to town
here alright just stroll into you know
some restaurant say you're Sean McVeigh
head coach of the Los Angeles Rams and
see how it goes
see what type of table you get and then
you go in one other time in the same
place and say you're Cooper Cup of the
Los Angeles Rams
and see if you can get a better table
and tell him what do you think I mean
sounds like an interesting round to give
me a shot though hmm what was your first
impression of your coach when you first
met him I mean he's a very intelligent
book coach I mean just to be able to be
around him in this year where he talks
and his understanding of the game it
really is a blessing to be around that
no I probably myself on the cerebral
part of the game and so being able have
a coach that really I think is in any
hands-down the smartest coach I've been
around so being able be around him is
pretty cool and you're really excited
about can you plan to them yeah in your
relationship with Jared golf let me in
on that one Cooper yeah
beginning of you know OTAs and
getting up here we tried to continue to
build chemistry and spend time working
on house and I'm talking about the game
day if I can see what he's saying we're
able to act together you know things
will start clicking even better built
that well Congrats on a great first
first game next up for you you got
Washington maybe you're gonna maybe
you're gonna start taking on Josh Norman
coming up next week right and then I
mean maybe maybe the dog if you will and
you will come out and you'll start
barking at them what do you think yeah
do what we need to do you know that's
all we need about an execute okay Cooper
Cup thanks for joining the show really
appreciate it look forward to our next
chat Congrats of course Cooper Cup see
oper
like my son the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on radio stations across
the country and audience if you liked
that video be sure to download our app
and I'll be sure to move week six games
to Saturday for that wedding you have to
go to